lá
engraçado né gente que que é isso que
está aqui no palco agora vocês devem
estar se perguntando que figura absurda
essa foi apresentada não sabiam nem de
onde é que eu ia chegar de um dia surge
ainda mais o que surgiu na frente de
vocês né
que que é isso às vezes um homem e uma
mulher
um homem que é ser mulher
este
só não sei o gate peruca praticamente 11
mas o que eu sou é uma drag queen
talvez seja a primeira que muitos de
vocês vejam nas suas vidas
espero que não seja a última drag queen
é um personagem um ator que cria o dessa
história aqui pra conquistar através da
arte eu uso esse visual para chegar até
vocês que arde causa esse contato nas
pessoas
eu sei que todo mundo está olhando e
pensando que coisa estranha né
alguns podem levam a nossa como ela
brilha como uma roupa dela chamativa as
garotas querem nossa que maquiagem
imensa
os homens podem ter me olhando e
pensando que coisa mais vulgar que coisa
estranha pessoas mais jovens podem achar
interessante e engraçada
pessoas mais velhas podem achar que eu
tô indo pro inferno acontece bastante
reveses
o fato é que todo mundo tenta miller
baseado em alguma coisa que a pessoa
traga em se você vai ler de acordo com
referencial que você tenha em você
todo mundo tá tentando achar em alguma
coisa que seja a no seu subconsciente
nessa história de vida para tentar
identificar esses seres estranhos subiu
aqui mas eu tô acostumado esse é o meu
papel como drag queen ser julgado
eu uso isso como plataforma para acessar
as pessoas mas eu estou sendo julgado
mas eu tô jogando vocês também acho que
é só aqui que está vindo é não
ainda também que a gente é assim e olha
que eu fiz de todo tipo de gente tem os
mais jovens e óleo por exemplo só que
talvez eles não estejam tão interessados
no assunto que eu vou abordar ou nos
outros assuntos abordados que a gente
jovem não está muito interessado em nada
as pessoas mais velhas as garotas chover
olhem pra minha mãe eu acho que ela pode
assumir a saia um pouco curta desculpa
minha mãe enfim base na sua aparência e
minha mãe também nos um vestidinho assim
os senhores de terno
acho que eles devem estar achando um
pouco absurda e eu preferia nem olhar
direto com eles que eu me sinta
intimidada
o eterno já causa isso na argentina
pessoa muito séria muito contida chega
dessa palhaçada toda assusta um pouco
é estranho tudo baseado nas roupas que a
gente tá uma roupa mais jovem a roupa de
um empresário a roupa de uma mãe
a roupa de uma advogada roupa de uma
drag queen
mas que bom que a gente consegue tirar
tudo isso que a gente tem a gente né
eu daqui a pouco já vou sair daqui vou
pro camarim desmonto que é uma montagem
daqui tira esse salto imenso que já está
me machucando graças a deus ea gente vai
se desmontando chega na sua casa você
tira esse terno você já não tem mais a
cara do empresário é o pai de família
você pode estar aqui parecendo minha mãe
mas no seu trabalho você é superlegal
super dinâmica parecendo uma jornalista
enfim a gente se desmonta a gente é
julgado por aquilo que a gente montou na
gente seja foram julgado por coisas que
vocês não conseguem mudar quando você
chega em casa
tipo eu tenho essa voz no dia a dia por
mais que eu seja um menininho que passe
despercebido no dia a dia eu tenho essa
voz não consigo mudar ela
eu abri a boca que o povo jeito quem
está falando com essa voz estranha ou
então vamos imaginar negro chega num
restaurante supersofisticado vão olhar
para ele com a mesma curiosidade de
olhar o andré viking subindo nesse palco
hoje o tipo da pessoa devia mesmo estar
aqui e não consegue tirar essa roupa de
negro
você vê uma travesti no metrô por
exemplo só olha pra ele pensa
provavelmente uma prostituta só que ela
não consegue tirar esse ser que ela é
são coisas maiores do que as roupas e
objetos e nós somos julgados o tempo
inteiro por essas coisas da gente pode
até pensar não imagina eu tenho amigos
gays
conheci através disso é respeito minha
cabeleireira ótima travesti incrível em
amigos negros a gente joga futebol junto
beleza mas será que só esse respeito
será que só essa aceitação é o
suficiente
eu acredito que não acredito
nós temos que apoiar as diferenças
será que quando essas pessoas tão
diferentes de vocês chegam próximo
o impacto já não é maior é muito fácil
você conviver no seu trabalho com um
negro um transexual
mas se você tivesse que contratar uma
pessoa para as empresas que contratarem
um transexual
será que é por isso que muitos deles
acabam realmente se tornando vítimas da
prostituição
será que se o seu pai resolveu se
assumir gay você aceitaria porque é o
filho tudo bem assim formando mas seu
pai pode ser subir e será que você
contrataria uma travesti para ser babá
de seu filho é algo que chegou muito
próximo né
e assusta sua filha namorar negro ainda
suscita muita gente é que a gente
percebe que quando a gente aceita a
gente aceita gente tolera desde que não
chegue perto mas é preciso apoiar
é preciso que a gente se aproxima das
pessoas
assim a gente consegue causar uma
revolução
vai chegar um momento que a gente vai
perceber que está apoiando não quando
você contratar a transexual para ser
babá vai ter contratado a vanessa ela é
babá de seu filho não tem vários amigos
gays não se tem o lucas o vinícius o
danilo
você não joga futebol com os seus amigos
negros ae o basquete né não joga com
seus companheiros de trabalho
é preciso que a gente olhe para as
pessoas e humanize arade encaixar as
pessoas em rótulos e definir então
pobremente ser humano
meu sonho
nós tenhamos a coragem de mais do que
respeitar mais do que tolerar não
tenhamos a coragem de apoiar as
diferenças no melhor ela é fox next que
eu vou